I want to start with the
what many Americans therefore do with it.
Some of you in this room may have grown up civil war buffs like I did.
I confess there millions of civil war tourists.
It has this enduring the military history in particular.
The battle history has an enduring eternal hole on our imagination,
but this is a first for me.
I just got this email,
well a couple of weeks ago from a woman named Nicky Blackburn in Charleston,
South Carolina has her photograph on it.
She's a real estate agent,
a pretty real estate agent,
and she wanted me to know as a civil war historian
did,
she and her firm have put a 24 hour web cam
on the Calhoun,
mentioned near Battery Park on the Cooper Law.
I was a Calhoun mansion near Battery Park and Lower Charleston and which looks
out directly on the fort Sumpter a mile away
so that you can dial up on the Internet and watch Fort Sumpter 24 hours a day.
Yeah.
Um,
I've experienced a wide variety of
bizarre phenomena
about the civil war with reenactors.
It's sites and so on and so on and so on.
And when you're on CSPAN,
if you're on cspan enough,
believe me,
you get every kind of late night.
Crazy American writing too.
But that's the first 24 hours when Cam Fort Sumpter,
I don't know what the hell you're supposed to see.
Okay.
Maybe they're ghost of confederates that come out at night and if they have the
right kind of night vision,
God,
I don't know,
but she's serious.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Yeah.
In 1863
on the beautiful,
um,
little hilltop cemetery and the south edge of the town of Gettysburg,
Pennsylvania,
small,
sleepy town,
large population of German,
a couple of little shoe factories,
a crossroads town market town.
They had a cemetery in this beautiful setting
and over the archway or,
or as part of the archway into that cemetery that would soon become famous.
There was a sign that read quote,
all persons found using firearms on these grounds will be prosecuted within the
utmost rigor of the law.
Okay.
Irony makes the world go around the world.
Go around.
Okay.
Today,
I want to take up with you
at least the beginnings of the question of confederate defeat and union victory.
Hold on.
A focus in particular on battle fronts.
There are numerous reasons,
explanations,
a terp causal interpretations for confederate defeat in union victory that have
flowed fourth and civil wars scholarship for years.
And we began to have a new kind of heated argument about it,
at least in books,
um,
about 10 years ago in part because of a series of two books by historians name
Hattaway in Beringer they wrote two big tomes.
One was entitled why the North won the civil war and the other was entitled why
the South lost the civil war,
not very subtle titles.
And they were the ones who posited,
uh,
more than anyone ever had before in a much more sophisticated way.
And I want to come back to that.
And it's part of exactly what's at stake in these two wonderful books you're
reading or have read or are about to read by Drew Faust and Gary Gallagher.
Gallagher is confederate war and the mothers of invention take up this question
of the so called loss of will.
Did the south lose the civil war because it ultimately lost its will to sustain
the fight.
There are many sides to that argument and I'll take it up in a moment.
I want to do,
I don't know what's happening in my sound.
It's your son.
It's too high.
Turn it down.
How about that?
How's that in the back row?
All right,
good.
Well anyway,
the civil wars we've said many times is the first great photograph,
Divan of American history.
The thousands of photographs.
We didn't had thousands more if people hadn't destroyed so many of them.
And of course Ken Burns is film series,
is in part in great part reliant on those photographs.
And he and his camera man,
of course they've cameras now.
They can take right inside almost these old the girl types and 10 types and,
and make them live in ways that,
uh,
they didn't at the time.
But that's an image of soldiers at the front smoking a pipe,
petting his dog.
It's an officer whose wife has come to the front.
Of course it's winter quarters and you're cold pepper courthouse,
Virginia 1863
okay.
They always built these cabins with these chimneys.
They will thousands of these with barrels on top.
Those are their chimneys.
Since I've been discussing this question,
the mobilization there many,
many images in the war from the war that show this kind of industrial might have
the north.
There's incredible photographs of the James River landings in Virginia by 1864
and just as far as the horizon can see,
supplies materiel piled up all over the wars.
This is an image in Virginia of the wagon trains of the Potomac army of the
Potomac by 1864 thousands of wagons.
This is mobilization for total war
and I just for the sake of reality,
want to show that also photographers like Matthew Brady and Alexander Gardner
and their troops of photographers.
It was Gardner in particular who went to Gettysburg after the battle of
Gettysburg and photograph so many of them.
So many of the dead.
This is a soldier,
a union soldier killed at Gettysburg.
It became a kind of macabre fascination,
especially in the north where these photographs were often displayed publicly.
Brady first started doing it in 62 and early 63 enhance that famous comment by
believe,
um,
George Templeton strong who said it was Brady who brought the war into people's
homes,
into their living rooms if they went to witness these photographs.
Now more on that,
perhaps at the end,
but go back with me now to this question of union victory confederate defeat.
We're not going to end the war to there.
That's next week and we're going to take the war today through 80 and 63 and
major military turning points where you can begin to make an argument from this
point forward.
From this point forward,
it would be very difficult for the confederacy to win,
although not impossible.
As we'll see in 1864 now on any list,
and I'm going to just give you a list out front and then we'll kind of take up
some of them,
but on any list of why they went north winds and why the south loses,
of course,
are these elements one resources and numbers goes without saying,
you know,
a world of war that is becoming more industrialized,
more modern in it's a weaponry and it's um,
to some extent it's tactics.
Although that's one of the reasons of course casualties.
In this war we're so ghastly because they were fighting with much more modern
weapons,
repeating rifles and of course the rifled muskets that could actually hit
something at 800 yards and could be deadly at two to 300 yards.
Think of that two to 300 yards.
You could hit something and see it,
but they were fighting with old tactics line upon line,
shoulder to shoulder double ranks.
If a front of the rank fell,
the second rank was supposed to be there and there were supposed to have loaded
their rifles in time to be up front while the ones that went back and reload it
again and an a veteran soldier in this war could load his muzzle loader a you
have the load,
the mini ball and the cap back here and then with your ramrod a veteran soldier
could do that without pressure about three times a minute because under the
pressure of about them being shot at and the cacophony of sound and terror and
fear soldier went through.
Sometimes it couldn't perform that and all over battlefields and this war they
would find dead soldiers sometimes with a rifle they had loaded three and four
times and never fired it.
They just kept loading but sort of lose their minds.
But in a war that is now foot with such weaponry and it's going to depend on
industrial production,
there is an argument that this war was won by the north and the shoe factories
of Lowell,
Massachusetts or the gun factories of new haven.
The gun factors is Springfield mass and the sheer productive Kapow or on those
railroads of the north,
which was so much better,
more efficient than the railroads of the south.
There's certainly an argument for that now.
Uh,
that handwriting was on the wall from the beginning of the war.
I'm in the lovely old book that David Donald did.
One's called why the north one,
he quotes on the first page of the book,
a newspaper in Lynchburg,
Virginia.
Some are 1861 battle of bull run hasn't even happened yet.
And all this fury for war,
the editor of the Lynchburg,
Virginia and wrote quote dependent upon Europe and the north for almost every
yard of cloth and every coat and boots and hats that we wear for our axes,
sides,
tubs and buckets.
In short,
for everything except our bread and meat,
it must occur to the south that if our relations with the north are ever,
we should,
they'd already been severed.
We should in all of the south,
not be able to close ourselves.
We could not fill our firesides plow,
our fields and our Mo,
our meadows.
In fact,
we should be reduced to a state more abject than we are willing to look at even
prospectively.
And yet all these things staring us in the face.
We shut her eyes and we go in blind fold.
Man,
was that prescient?
One of the most remarkable facts about the American civil war and Jane's
Macpherson makes a big deal of this and battle cry of freedom over and over,
is that despite their lack of this product to industrial productivity in
relation to the north,
it is amazing how long the south held out an amazing,
how close they actually came to winning their version or definition of victory.
The North had more banking,
more labor capacity,
everything to an argument has always been made that the north in the end had
superior political leadership.
I,
he,
Abraham Lincoln,
now lock can be made of this.
And a lot has been made of this and book after book comparing Lincoln with
Davis.
Um,
and there's no question that as an executive,
as a leader,
as a politician,
as a manipulator of people,
uh,
for in terms of an acumen,
even a genius for politics and organization.
Abraham Lincoln is about as good as we've ever had.
Jefferson Davis on the other hand,
a smart and brilliant man that he was a long military career,
long service in the Senate,
the war department and all else was nevertheless not a very good executive.
He always had one foot sort of tied in the states rights tradition
and that other foot now really where his soul was by 1860260360 four wasn't
trying to create a nation,
a centralized nation state,
doing all the things that the stays rights tradition said he should not,
he was not in the end,
a great war president and impart some have argued because he would have
preferred to be on the battlefield and not in an executive's role.
He listened to those generals who were his friends and didn't tend to listen to
those who were not.
He often made um,
sort of leadership mistakes such as the time he personally went out west.
I'll come to that in a moment during the just before the great campaign for
Chattanooga in late summer and then the fall of 1863 for,
for the possession of this terribly important strategic crossroads in South East
Tennessee,
the sort of gateway into the deep South crossroads of two Great Southern Rivers,
crossroads of the two main east,
west southern railroads and so on.
He goes out there in the wake of the fall of Chattanooga when Braxton brags
army,
it had to retreat south and he goes to the whole journey that been terrible.
Dissension in that confederate army.
They all the generals want to brag,
fired and Davis goes up,
goes out personally to the camp,
gathers all the generals around with bread,
standing there and asked all the other generals whether they thought they should
have a new commander
and to a man.
They basically all said yes in front of their commander and then Davis
reappointed him.
It was one of the most bizarre decisions of the war.
Brag,
Brag was a disaster.
But this is the sort of thing that [inaudible] Davis and Brag went back years
and they were old friends and Emmy Davis made some strange decisions.
But Davis also with handicapped tremendously politically by the state's rights
tradition.
And I would argue one other thing,
and it's really a third reason you can put on this long list of why the north is
going to win this war.
The North had an existing political culture,
it had an existing political party system.
And we can argue that that political parties isn't,
was greatly divided.
And it was by 63 you've got what are called Peace Democrats.
The Democratic Party in the north is beginning to argue for a negotiated peace
and end of the war,
a divided America,
confederate states of America,
United States of America.
And in 1864 they're gonna run it in Mcclellan on that camp,
on that platform.
And we'll talk about how pivotal this 64 election was next week.
But you had an existing party system that could organize politics,
they could organize descent,
that could channel opposition.
And it also gave Abraham Lincoln the Cudgel or the,
the,
the whip of partisanship.
He could build enough of a coalition to sustain not only the war effort,
but also to pull off some of that remarkable legislation that I started to talk
about last time.
Um,
especially economic legislation that really in some ways for a while at least
transform,
uh,
the American central government.
Fourth,
one of the principal reasons the north is going to win this war is that it does
ultimately through some remarkable diplomacy,
especially by Charles Francis Adams in London,
the u s ambassador to Great Britain,
grandson of John Adams,
son of John Quincy.
The fact that in the end,
the union government succeeds and keeping Great Britain extensibly out of the
war,
at least militarily,
mostly out of the war,
is absolutely crucial to union victory.
Had Britain had,
had Lee wanted to Antidem just this is what macpherson means.
And many other historians are really doing this before Jim was,
but,
but he's,
he's made it his own argument that you can't understand you and in veteran
confederate defeat without dealing with all kinds of contingencies,
moments in the war.
If this hadn't happened in,
that can't happen.
If that doesn't happen,
then that can't happen.
And so,
so,
you know,
putting your eggs in any one basket to explain this or for that matter,
anything in history is bad idea.
But one of those contingencies is if Lee winds at Antietam succeeds and moving
further into the north threatens northern cities and the British government
formally recognize the confederacy and formally sent British troops to fight
with the confederacy rather than just in a sense sending them a shadow navy,
which was helping the confederacy and building them ships could have had a very
different outcome to this war.
If the United States that had to fight a second front in Canada against the
British,
just imagine the possible outcomes.
So very important factor.
Fifth much has always been made about the,
the,
the so-called in the end,
superior military leadership of the north in the end.
And we'll deal with this much more next week and a little bit today on grant and
Sherman and Sheridan and,
and,
and General Thomas and a few others actually finally become the principal
leaders of this entire ultimately coordinated west and east strategic effort
against the south.
You can argue,
although I think too much is often made of this.
You can argue that in some ways grant won the war and there are books that
literally argue that,
that want to give grant in so many ways,
credit,
um,
for union victory.
And that will argue,
and I'll come back to this next week,
that in some ways is great.
As Robert E.
Lee was as a battlefield commander,
as daring and as he was the risk that he took the ability he had to somehow see
a terrain to see land,
to uh,
to see the possibilities of a landscape and how to move huge numbers of men
through it.
And the way that he could inspire through a quite amazing level of charisma,
his offer or his,
his officer's staff.
There's a lot to the fact that Robert [inaudible] himself had a lot to do with
sustaining the confederate war effort as long as it lasted.
And Gary Gallagher is going to make a pretty big deal of that in your book
confederate war.
It's just worth remembering that Gallagher's source set by and large is the
officer corps of Lee's army.
Uh,
it's a fine book,
but you've got to remember what were his sources are coming from.
These are Lee's lieutenants that he's quoting over and over and over,
and they became about as loyal to a military commander as anyone has ever been
in American history.
And then six or whatever number I'm on,
and we've dealt with this a good deal already.
We'll come back to it later.
The policy of emancipation,
the trans formation of this war into far beyond its original limited aims into a
war that will become a war of conquest,
a wars Lincoln to comes to define it in late 62 and it's absolutely clear in 63
has to be a war to the ultimate aim of the unconditional surrender of the south,
which means a war on their resources,
on their society,
on their transportation systems,
and on slavery,
their labor system,
their greatest source of wealth and wore on the cities.
There are people,
or as Sherman will say,
he wanted to make Georgia howl.
All right.
No,
that's a short list.
Now fold into that this theory,
it's a theory that in the end you add all this up,
resources,
political leadership,
military leadership,
the policy of unconditional surrender,
emancipation and keeping Great Britain out of the war,
diplomacy and so on and so on.
Um,
and battlefield victories,
as I'll point out in the second,
you get this argument for the loss of morale,
loss of will.
Now,
this was fashioned by his story and his really who cut their teeth in the
Vietnam era,
and they argued that there are plenty of examples throughout history of
insurgencies,
like the confederacy.
That's what it was.
It's the big one.
It's not just a little gorilla army pecking away at a,
you know,
oil lines.
But they argued that the many cases in history and the most obvious one in the
1970s and eighties to Americans was north Vietnam,
which held out for a generation,
really two generations against the French empire and then against the United
States of America,
the biggest military machine in the world.
They lost three and a half million people and they won.
So suddenly through that experience,
through those eyes,
some American historians,
we're going to look back at the civil war and say,
you know what?
Whoa,
wait a minute here.
You know,
why didn't the confederacy a hole out in longer?
Yeah,
there were bread riots.
There was some starvation.
It was a hell of a lot of desertion.
But maybe that's telling us something.
In the end.
It wasn't just Marcus Roberts,
Maurice Robert in his loyal men.
It was the civilians behind the war.
It was the home front.
This is what drew Faust.
I went to all these women's diaries stretch to try to test and the argument
essentially is that the south didn't have a sufficient degree of nationalism
of an emotional psychological devotion to a historic nation state that they
would do anything to save and preserve in the ways,
let's say that the Germans did to the absolute bitter end against the Russians
and the allies on the western front and the Second World War barons in Hato.
I love the example of Paraguay.
I,
you know,
nobody knows anything about the story of Paraguay in the way it held out against
Brazil.
I think it was a,
it was an early 20th century example and then there've been other kinds of
guerrilla insurgencies over the years.
At the bottom of this argument was why didn't more confederate forces rather
than surrender go off and form guerrilla bands?
Why didn't the American civil war in the way so many civil wars in,
they never quite end band of 20 men here and 300 they're going off into the
hills supplying themselves somehow forming a kind of alternative insurgency that
never quite die.
You read a lot of loss cars,
literature,
the by the late 19th century and you would almost think that is what happened,
but it didn't happen.
Beringian Hattaway have also argued that that that in part the south,
once it begins to lose the war in [inaudible] 63 and 64 that it was southern
unionist that began to come to the fore,
that there were large and there were large pockets of unionism,
people who didn't really support the confederate war effort in western Virginia,
western North Carolina,
eastern Tennessee,
upland,
Georgia,
and those hills that Sherman's army begins to move through and discovers there's
some white folk around who want to support him.
In fact,
Sherman was much kinder to those Georgia whites then he was to those Georgia
blacks who tried to gain freedom by coming to his army moron,
Sherman's racism next week.
Now in the end,
this is an argument that what the south lacked was a deep mystical,
emotional level of nationalism.
Well that's been countered,
that's been countered by numerous historian.
Uh,
drew Faust is one of them in an earlier book called the creation of confederate
nationalism.
Uh,
sh she's been joined or she actually joined a whole group of historians studying
this Id.
It's been one of the recurring fascinating questions about the civil war.
And the question is essentially what kind of nationalism did the confederacy
actually developed and frozen?
It only lasted for years.
I mean,
the question really is,
was there a confederate nation or were they just a band of states that came
together in military defense of homeland?
Well,
their arguments on all sides of this,
um,
and I'll just just say a couple things.
I think those,
the ends,
it's drew Faust is,
it's John mccartle,
numerous historians.
The weight of the best argument I think is that the south did indeed rather
quickly.
And is it a lot of lessons in this historically develop a serious level of this
mystical kind of nationalism.
They developed an ideology that they said their nation was based on.
They said right up front at the beginning of the war,
Jefferson Davis speech after speech after speech,
he said the confederacy is the logical vessel of the American revolution.
What the confederacy really was was the carry over of 1776 1861 with 1776 the
George Washington,
they will argue was the founder of the confederacy.
Yeah.
The True American democracy was in this resistance to centralization.
They created seals and songs and images in heroes and paintings,
poetry all over the place.
They use religion.
The same kind of millennial Christianity,
the same kind of theory of a divine providence that northerners are praying too
and arguing for is the same kind of millennialism the confederates are going to
argue for.
They're going to say that they are the chosen nation.
Okay.
All over the place among southern clergy.
That argument is put forth especially early in the war and then lastly,
slavery.
It is in some ways almost amazing how much southerners began to defend slavery
and the ways they began to defend slavery during the war,
and the ways that the big end to link it to their nation,
the confederacy of how the confederacy was put into this world,
to perfect slavery,
to improve it,
to show the world that this slave society,
this system is biracial system.
We're one race is the labor and the other races,
the educated to show the world the possibilities of that.
Yeah.
Even developed a whole variety of traveling confederate minstrel minstrel
groups.
Minstrelsy had been primarily a phenomenon of the north.
Often the audiences were largely white working class,
but the war,
suddenly you had these confederate troops of minstrels all over the place and
new songs and new poems,
uh,
were,
were written that were tied now to the sort of fade of the confederacy.
I'll just give you one example.
There was one minstrel troupe known as these were whites and black face keeping
morale up.
One of them was called Lincoln's intelligent contrabands
and one little verse ran,
I'd rather work to cotton patch and die on corn.
And Bacon,
then live up north on good white bread of abolition,
Macon.
And it gets worse and it goes on and on.
And,
and,
and the story or the argument of all these confederate minstrel songs and the
poetry of are based on is that black people don't want to be free,
don't want anything to do with his free labor nonsense.
I'm going to stay where they are.
Now I invite you to read Gallagher and foster on this and Gallagher is going to
make pretty aggressive argument against the loss of wealth thesis and he's going
to argue the confederate nationalism ultimately resided and those armies,
uh,
the armies that stuck it out against almost unbelievable.
Ah,
all right.
But in 1863,
the war had major military turning points.
And let me take you through some of that.
Well,
the three major ones,
uh,
with some dispatch,
but these are,
I mean on that short list of I believe five major turning points in the civil
war.
I mentioned Gettysburg and Vicksburg.
Well kind of add to that if you want,
if you would,
the fall of port Hudson only a week after Vicksburg out on the Mississippi and
then the ultimate fall final fall of Chattanooga to union hands by the fall of
1863 now,
some maps are in order.
Yeah,
confederacy.
You won a major victory at the battle of Chancellorsville near uh,
sorry.
It just slipped off the map.
There it is.
Just west of Fredericksburg.
First Week of May,
1863 this was yet again.
Uh,
you'll remember the whole,
the previous year,
a year before this McClellan and invaded the peninsula up toward Richmond,
the seven days campaign and all the rest defeated.
Retreated.
Lee then invaded the north.
He's going to do exactly the same thing in the summer of 1863 and the wake of
what was without a question,
a decisive victory at Chancellorsville.
Lee held a,
a council of war in Richmond with Davis and other generals.
This time,
of course,
stonewall Jackson was not there.
He was shot and killed by his own men after the battle at night of
Chancellorsville,
he lived about a week,
that little house where he died and the amputated his arm is a shrine today.
I do you want to see some civil war weirdness?
Go to the stonewall Jackson Shrine.
Um,
and if you ever saw the movie gods,
if he ever endured the movie gods and generals,
all four and a half hours of it,
which I did cause I had to write a review of it.
You know that they took almost a half hour to have stonewall Jackson die.
I'm sorry.
For those of you who are stonewall Jackson fans,
it's just quite remarkable.
But any rate,
Lee lost a terribly important commander,
then there's no question about it and it will always leave.
And southern lower.
You know,
what if Jackson had lived or what if he'd had Jackson at Gettysburg?
What if he'd had Jackson at cold harbor,
where of it?
At any rate,
Lee went to Davis and said,
let me invade the North again.
Davis was a little cautious because the first time it didn't work,
and I almost lost the war year ago.
James Longstreet now second in command,
the lead and the,
and the army of northern Virginia had another idea and launched.
It almost always did.
And there's a whole debate and civil war military history about just whether
long streets should have been listened to throughout 63 long streets.
Idea was to take,
uh,
at least two divisions of not an entire core of infantry,
as many as possibly 20,000 men and moved them out west as long street.
Where is the war was being lost in the western,
you know what,
he was right on that at least that,
no,
and always in civil war scholarship,
there's been this question,
you know,
did Lee,
he ultimately lose the war because of his obsession with Virginia is home state
is home land and not allowing confederate troops to be moved west.
Well,
they weren't moving west.
Not at this point in time.
Okay.
All over the war.
Now,
even though lead one is major victory at Chancellorsville,
the confederacy was potentially him then potentially.
So Liza response to this was daring and how do you want it?
Gettysburg,
decisive,
live.
We wouldn't be,
well,
I don't know what we'd be debating.
I'm not sure.
I want to know what we'd be debating,
but Lee did decide to go west up over into the upper Shenandoah valley and
invade this time all the way into Pennsylvania,
which he did in June,
okay.
Lincoln's commander of the army of the Potomac.
Now seriously defeated was a general named hooker.
Hooker resigned the 28th of June,
1863 and was replaced by General named George Gordon meet only five days was,
excuse me,
only three days before what would become the greatest battle of the war.
Okay.
What Gettysburg became
was in some ways an attempt by the confederate,
excuse me,
the Union army.
I'll prove that for you.
It's an effort by the Union army is blue here,
of course,
to catch up with Lee's army as an invaded up into Pennsylvania and to stay
between Lee's army in Washington DC.
It's in some ways a replay what had happened just the year before now,
they actually ended up meeting at this little town of Gettysburg,
almost by mistake.
They hadn't planned that Lee wanted to move all of his troops into central
Pennsylvania.
The whole idea here was to live off the land and the rich farm land of
Pennsylvania to take the war out of ravaged central Virginia,
relieve Richmond.
Uh,
and Lee believed tap in to the war,
weariness of the north,
and possibly even reinvigorate British intervention
when a lot of likelihood at that point.
But you know,
he,
he hoped at any rate that there might be some possibility.
It was a great calculated risk.
Okay.
Um,
you know,
had it worked,
who knows?
It did not.
They collide in near Gettysburg because a,
a group of a confederate infantry,
we're marching toward the town from the West on July 1st,
1863 because they'd heard there were shoes in Gettysburg and there were
confiscating,
by the way,
everything,
cattle,
hogs,
food,
everything they could take from Pennsylvania farms.
And rather than tapping into war weariness in the north,
what leak accomplished was to stimulate resistance in the north.
Nothing like an army invading your land,
stealing your at your animals to a cause you some consternation.
Lee's army also took scores of free blacks living in southern and central
Pennsylvania and shuttled them quickly back into the south as slaves.
And when this got into the press,
uh,
it also had an effect on northern morale
the first day at Gettysburg.
And I can't go into the kind of detail I'd love to hear and I know some of you
would like me to,
although I'm going to invite those of you who are military history enthusiasts
to an evening session,
perhaps next week,
perhaps the week after on a Wednesday if anybody wants.
But we can go into more detail on this and you can open your veins and get a
really good shot,
a military history if you'd like.
And if if you o d that's your fault.
The first day at Gettysburg was a confederate victory,
almost a complete route.
It's actually nighttime that stopped it the second day at Gettysburg.
If you look at this map over here,
you'll note that the union battle line,
the union army barely got there in time by the second day to actually oppose
Lee's army.
They had marched all day,
some of these union troops in March,
30 miles in a day just to get there.
But the second day at Gettysburg were attacks,
massive attacks on the two ends of the line,
left Lincoln,
right flank of the union armies,
which we're both very high ground.
If any of you've ever,
how many of you been to Gettysburg,
you know,
little round top and copes Hilden Large hills,
huge battles were fought on those hills and joy to 1862,
uh,
with huge numbers of casualties,
especially for the confederates.
By the third day long street urged vehemently that Lee retreat,
a strategic retreat and move south southward and then toward Washington and
threatened us capitol.
But to choose other ground to fight on because of the way these hills and ridges
were set up in front of them.
Long Street Council,
a kind of strategic defensive move.
They are on enemy land enemy territory.
Every day is a total risk here.
And they've got a real problem with their supply line,
but least said no.
His blood was up and the evidence all over the dispatches.
Lee wanted to win there.
He wanted to fight.
And as I'll come back to this question next week about Lee's own psyche for war,
and what they said happened to his eyes.
One,
one,
it was time for battle.
So on the third day at Gettysburg,
he ordered a concentration at the center and it became the largest military
assault of the war,
the largest infantry assault of the civil war.
It's known as Pickett's charge because it's name for one of the three division
commanders,
uh,
who led it,
um,
George Pickett,
who hid behind a barn through the whole damn thing.
By the way,
while two of his brigade commanders were killed and all of his 13 kernels in his
brigade were killed or wounded.
So Pickett's charge the charge of 13,000 men for one hour across a wide open
field,
slightly rising towards the ridge lasted about one hour and almost exactly one
half of those 13,000 men were killed or wounded and never got back to the ridge.
They started from,
it was Lee's greatest mistake in the civil war.
He knew it.
He wrote out in the middle of this field and the thing was over as the men
strike were straggling back.
Those who survived and he kept going up to them and saying,
it's all my fault.
It's all my fault.
Please help me.
He even offered his resignation to Jefferson Davis a couple of weeks later,
but of course,
David's wasn't going to take it.
The great significance of Gettysburg,
there's many things.
Uh,
it's several things.
It's the greatest battle of the war in terms of its sheer scale.
Casualties were ghastly.
28,000 casualties in three days.
That's dead,
wounded and missing on the confederate side.
One third of all the men and gauge,
we're dead or wounded at the end of it.
On the Union side,
there were 23,000 casualties.
That's one of every four.
My Guy,
Charley Brewster,
whose letters I edited,
was actually held in reserve.
They didn't even get there in time.
The 10th mass was that was brought out to be burial Cruz and his letters above
about the fields,
Gettysburg or just quite almost unbelievable,
isn't a particularly poignant letter where he,
he,
they always rifled the pockets of the dead.
He rifles the pockets of a con dead confederate soldier.
Okay.
And in his pockets is a letter,
a love letter home.
And he reads that letter and he quotes from it to his own mother and any
barriers to the guy and saved the letter.
And this was his job for about three days in a rainstorm bearing union and
confederate dead.
It is Getty's.
It is the carnage at Gettysburg,
the vast number of dead 56 odd thousand casualties overall that forced the
United States government to create the first national cemetery,
which would be created at Gettysburg.
And that's of course why Lincoln went there the next fall to give the Gettysburg
address.
Now,
let's strategically,
it's hugely important.
Lee had to retreat as fast as he could.
The great problem now for the next week was whether me,
the union commander would follow this up and push like hell in spite of the,
uh,
the how badly hurt his army was.
And Lincoln was sending dispatch after dispatch to me,
please move.
You've got the menu.
Nixon was saying things like,
you've got them in your grip,
destroyed them.
The war will be over.
The war will be over and lead and me didn't move for three days.
And Lee's army escaped on the 13th and 14th of July on a pontoon bridge.
They hastily managed to build what was left of Lee's army,
managed to get across the Potomac River back into Virginia to fight again.
Gettysburg's a major union victory,
but it could have been even bigger
out west
and terribly important.
You could argue even more important
where the sieges in the capture of two major places,
I guess you'd call them fortresses or ports along the Mississippi river,
Vicksburg and port Hudson.
Vicksburg was laid under C.
Vicksburg had been brought under siege from months by a union army commanded by
Ulysses grant.
I mean they,
they had even at one point tried to alter the course of the Mississippi River
with the,
with the biggest military engineering scheme,
the world that ever hatched.
And it did.
It didn't really work at a big river,
don't mess with it.
But finally,
grant was able to put Vicksburg in the spring of 1863 under siege,
mostly from the east,
and it was especially under complete lockdown siege from May 22nd to the first
week of July,
in which time the civilian population of Vicksburg that was left and a roughly
30,000 garrison of good of a confederate army began to starve.
The civilians were living in caves because much of their housing was destroyed
by artillery bombardment.
On June 28th the confederate commander John [inaudible],
received a petition from his own troops signed by lots of them,
which said,
in part quote,
if you cannot feed us,
you had better surrender.
And so Pemberton sued for survey.
Did Sue,
he asks for surrender terms.
He met with grant on the 3rd of July,
the same afternoon as Pickett's charge is happening in the east.
They don't know it.
And Pemberton surrounded 30,000 confederate troops,
the blink of an eye on July 4th 80 63 central Mississippi would within weeks be
abandoned by confederate forces and the whole of central and northern
Mississippi would come under union control.
And that is by,
by the way,
folks,
the most densely populated slave region anywhere in the south.
And it is the escape of slaves now by the hundreds and then thousands into
grants lines that forced his hand and the creation of numerous contraband camps
all over northern Mississippi and Tennessee.
And even down in Mississippi a few days later on July 8th that port Hudson down
the Mississippi,
just north of Baton Rouge,
a second fort surrendered.
The two had been under sieged since May.
And when Port Hudson surrendered,
the Mississippi now was completely in union hands and union control.
And the 16th of July,
a merchant steam boat tied up in New Orleans,
having successfully traveled from Saint Louis all the way down the river on
harassed at all by confederate guns.
And Lincoln famously wrote his memo or telegraph to grant saying,
now the father of waters again goes and vexed to the sea.
It's terribly important because if he doesn't look at a map,
you realize now that by controlling the entire Mississippi river and the region
around it,
you're not only are our sewing a havoc in a southern society,
freeing slaves,
confiscating land and property,
controlling the south greatest seaports,
but you've cut the confederacy in half and one of the confederacy's largest
supply lines was through Texas.
They were actually being supported to this point in time by the French through
Mexico.
All that was a supplier and it never worked terribly.
Well.
Now clock is running out on me.
That's okay because what happens,
the Chattanooga doesn't.
That could happen to us I think next to the end of 1863 which is a nice place to
pick it up next time.
But let me leave you with this.
Okay.
Across the south.
This was horrible news and especially when Chattanooga is going to fall in the
fall.
It's even worse.
News and these kinds of expressions now came from southern leaders and privates
in the army and women at home and here comes your loss of morale thesis
on July 28th after the fall for port Hudson and Vicksburg and the the Barco,
the disaster at Gettysburg,
the confederate chief of ordinance,
Josiah Gorgeous,
wrote into his diary quote,
events have succeeded one another with disastrous rapidity.
One brief month ago.
We were apparently at the point of success,
Lee was in Pennsylvania.
It's threatening Harrisburg and even Philadelphia.
Vicksburg seem to laugh at all of grants,
efforts to scorn.
Now the picture is just as somber as it was bright then it seems incredible that
human power could affect such a change and so brief a space.
Yesterday we rode on the pinnacle of success.
Today absolute ruins seems to be our portion,
the confederacy totters to its destruction.
The war isn't over,
and I'll argue next week the confederacy still could have one its version of
victory in 1864 but those battlefields successes of 63
were handwriting on the wall.